in this lecture we look in some depth
into various properties of Poisson
processes these properties would be
quite hard to study if one were to
proceed just analytically by
manipulating formulas however by using
memorylessness and our intuitive
understanding of what the Poisson
process really is they become quite
simple and mathematical manipulations
can be avoided almost entirely we will
start by arguing that the sum of
independent Poisson random variables is
Poisson but we will then establish the
much stronger statement that if we merge
two independent Poisson processes we
again obtain a Poisson process we will
see that we can exploit this fact to
solve some problems that would be quite
difficult otherwise once more intuitive
reasoning is the key finally we will
spend some time discussing a phenomenon
that goes under the name of random
incidence a Poisson process has been
running you show up at a certain time
you look at the size of the
inter-arrival interval during which you
show up it turns out that this
inter-arrival interval that you get to
observe is not a typical one it tends to
be larger than the typical inter-arrival
interval we will understand what exactly
is going on build some intuition and
realize that this is a general
phenomenon that also shows up in many
other contexts